a ver yo
no sabía nada
me llegaron los ecos de las fronteras
francesas
brasil también
y de la red niña
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y desde la primera vuelta
desde la primera vuelta
ellos elegían su presidente y en sus
decisiones vi lo que estas personas
significaban plenamente el estado en el
que se encuentra la paz de su pueblo en
todos los puntos del territorio es un
estado de exasperación y el sentimiento
de haber logrado en un estado de
emergencia ecológica social y ahora una
vez más lo vemos esta noche un estado de
emergencia política
porque el tablero
que están viendo ustedes allí
fue así
como fue querido no por el pueblo
francés sino por las instituciones de la
quinta república y por este extraño
sistema de sorteo que conduce a pedirles
que escojan entre dos palabras
ustedes se siente a la vez que son esas
dos palabras terribles para uno mismo y
que no son de la misma naturaleza y cada
uno de ustedes
está
ante su conciencia sin saber qué hacer
sin saber qué decisión para tomar esa es
la condición humana
estar siempre
enfrentado a decisiones que a veces son
difíciles de tomar
y bien
que pasó la última vez
les dije lo que les vuelvo a decir no
conozco su cólera compatriotas todos
ustedes de quienes hablé hace un momento
conozco su cólera su rabia no saben no
se abandonen
para que no se dejen no dejen que
ustedes cometan errores que pueden ser
irreparables
mientras la vida continúa el combate
continua
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y mi deber es decirles
como por ser el más viejo de todos
ustedes
y lo que tenemos que hacer
es lo que cuadra con el mito de sísifo
la piedra cae pues vamos a volverlo a
subir
ustedes no son débiles ni tampoco
cobardes
ustedes están en capacidad de librar
esta batalla y la siguiente y la
siguiente todas las batallas que haya
que librar ustedes están en capacidad de
librar les mírenme a mí nunca he
abandonado nunca ha excedido nunca bajé
la mirada y de esta manera es como hemos
construido esta fuerza ahora está en sus
manos son ustedes que tienen que
trabajar en la próxima batalla ya
constituimos el polo popular porque ella
estaba
muchos pudieron apoyarse allí para votar
por nosotros y traernos a este hasta
este punto las batallas están por
librarse y están ante ustedes no
cometamos el error de acobardarnos desde
el comienzo sabemos por quién nunca
votaremos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y en cuanto al resto
como ya les dije
hace 5 años
recuerdan ustedes que hubo algunos
daños después de nuestra declaración se
dijo ellos los franceses son capaces de
saber qué hacer son capaces de decidir
lo que es bueno para el país nunca
perderemos nuestra confianza en la
democracia entonces no le den su voto a
la señora aleph en
ahora pues bueno yo lo sé bien
y lo repito porque a veces sucede que
aun cuando diga las cosas es como si no
las hubiera dicho entonces lo digo de
nuevo en esta parte de la película no
hay que dar los votos a madame lo que no
tiene que darle su voto a la señora lo
que no
no hay que darle un solo voto a la
señora lópez
[Aplausos]
no hay que darle un solo voto de la
señora del hotel
[Aplausos]
pero el bono
para esta parte creo que el mensaje ha
sido claro ahora ya vamos a hacer
nosotros bueno vamos a abrir una página
y las 310 mil personas que me
apadrinaron expresarán su sito de vista
dicho esto no nos escondamos
la violencia de la decepción la
violencia de la decepción
como son
todavía se dirige a lo que se hubiera
podido hacer
y todo lo demás
todo lo que yo estaba pensando hacer lo
que creía hacer
inmediatamente para mañana los equipos
que estaban listos para desplegarse y
trabajar para hacer todas las tareas que
teníamos que asumir
si es una excepción pero al mismo tiempo
como ocultarnos
como no reconocer
el orgullo por el trabajo realizado el
polo popular existe si nosotros no
estuviéramos ahí sí que pasaría lo que
quedaría del polo popular nada pero
construimos esta fuerza la hemos
construido entre todos
me dirijo a ustedes a todos los que
están en esta sala
no para reconfortarlos compro con
palabras significantes ni para calmarles
el ánimo no realmente no no quiero que
me reconforten yo solamente reconozco mi
deber y espero que ustedes hagan lo
mismo la lucha continúa
no dijo
a todos aquellos que hasta ahora no han
querido escucharnos les volvemos a decir
aquí está la fuerza tenemos una
estrategia el polo popular tenemos un
programa tenemos ante nosotros otras
elecciones en cada etapa siempre
ocuparemos el lugar que nos corresponde
piensen bien en ello ahora por supuesto
los más jóvenes me van a decir
ok todavía no hemos llegado no lo hemos
logrado
pero bueno ya vendrán ya llegarán sigan
haciendo siempre mejor
[Aplausos]